we should talk about you know first of
all thank you everyone listen to Broca's
yeah um yeah I mean it's like the
reception has been fantastic um that's
majority of people really enjoy it it's
a tie someone said two million streams
now that's what that's what rappers say
after they put out it hit well at the
vast majority of people seem to really
enjoy that and the reception is
fantastic that's what young Doug says
puts out album the reception is
fantastic no but I mean like people seem
to be diggin it and I mean two million
two million streams is gonna hit in like
an hour that's in five days yeah that's
crazy and the vegetables and wild four
or some yeah that is crazy man uh I mean
it's more than I ever thought like you
know this is now doubled the first week
of walkman walkman hit a million in a
week yeah and if you uh you know shout
out to hip hop heads we get it yeah mods
think we're trash we get it I just like
I think it's so funny that there's this
personal vendetta against us I think
it's pretty [ __ ] hilarious it's like
man who gives a [ __ ] no I've no it's cuz
they're good they're good they're good
moderators they take their job seriously
yeah yeah you're right you're right and
that's good we can't ya can't do that ya
know they take it they tell ya we're
working hard they're working hard not to
be fair I get it they're they they're
passionate about it that's fair but I
mean like the petty I commend the level
of peteus
hilarious honestly [ __ ] it label is is
trashed some of the comments in there
were funny interesting a lot of
positives one of the funny couple funny
negative comments and I don't actually
know this is on reddit so this is on
YouTube someone said what a sellout move
this is obviously a cash grab and I
thought yeah that was so great yeah and
it hit me that like doing the SeatGeek
bit at the end it hit me like oh [ __ ] as
usually have a connotation of like
making a shitload of money no but we
that was the whole punchline what the
punchline was that they paid for the
music video that implies there was no
cash on top we get a [ __ ] fee for
that
yeah that's what yeah that's so I think
that's one thing I thought at least for
the people who listened to us my guess
would be interested to know yeah that's
the irony the whole video is that we
couldn't afford it yeah weird we needed
a brand sponsor to afford the videos so
the irony is that weird a broke [ __ ]
because we had to find getting money for
that music video was the hardest thing
oh my [ __ ] god and it happened in the
week before shooting yeah we had to like
scrambled to find money basically mmm
yeah and I've never I don't think we
should say the budget but no no no it
was a lot of [ __ ] money it's the most
we've ever done yeah yeah like I I'm
very grateful that SeatGeek
oh yeah you know as much as like david
dobrik [ __ ] everything and and whatever
you think of sikhi they're a really
[ __ ] open-minded company in terms of
working with creators yeah and like yeah
I know you know shut it too - Ian from C
geek but he really is like totally 100%
on board with with what we're doing and
what other people are doing and he's
like however you want to promote us like
yeah and make it happen and so like that
you know that's a whole that all that
whole commercial was was that was none
of their input we we did that and yeah
we came up with that and and they were
like yeah sure do it not only that of
[ __ ] you know without saying numbers
so they they get they gave us an amount
and we gave us a bag
they gave us a bag we're still short we
were still short yeah yeah and we still
had the source other money from other
places which I cannot disclose at this
time yeah angel investors angels yeah
truly angels because they came in and be
like 11th [ __ ] hour and shout out to
Aidan for dealing with all the madness
because he kept sending me estimates and
I'm like dude you know that we got to
come down here we got to come down here
this is it's gonna be you know is there
any way to do this so I think it's worth
knowing for some people like for that
whole car that middle section where Cody
and I are in that hot rod that is car
[ __ ] just so you guys know is some of
the most expensive [ __ ] from a
production standpoint we had to dedicate
a whole we had it
it's insane we did that video on one day
for the most for for starters we didn't
we didn't day and a half but I guess I
don't technically count that half-day I
mean you have to count because most of
it was the at the half-day was doing the
ad which thank [ __ ] we did that yeah you
know but also the car the car took three
hours yeah three hours yeah for 15
seconds yeah because they had to build a
[ __ ] mount yeah yeah outside of the
car yeah hang the camera yeah the car
rig takes like an hour and a half and we
had some we had some good [ __ ] we had
a great that we had a great team for
that those guys are not [ __ ] they
were not amateurs um and they were able
to build that [ __ ] fast and break it
down fast you know fast is relative but
mounting it to that hot rod was tough
yeah I was like the hood and [ __ ] was
all it's just a weird shape and I
remember them like looking at it and
Neema being like you guys gonna be able
to do this and they're kind of like yeah
we should be able to but you know
whatever
yeah so that was one funny comment I
thought that people thought we made like
this insane amount of money on that
video and we didn't know I also in that
same vein there were a couple comments
actually more than a couple I read like
a solid handful of comments that were
like what the [ __ ] is this dude half
this video is an ad or half this music
video as an ad yeah no it's not it's not
the music video is a separate just turn
it off yeah then it's 100% a music video
and 0% yeah yeah yeah you can we stuck
the ad in the middle of the music yeah
then I would be totally understandable
understanding of you being pissed but
it's not it's after you can just it's
kind of funny to sit through a minute I
have
and be like [ __ ] yeah like you got duped
wait it's over that's it dude they
[ __ ] with me I had no idea that was an
ad the whole time I didn't get that was
a [ __ ] ad oh that's yeah that's funny
um a lot but a lot of positive comments
which now it like I said the vast
majority yeah of comments were
overwhelmingly positive yes which is
super dope I'll put put this into
perspective we had almost doubled the
budget for that music video that we did
for Sookie so for people trying to give
me something that Sookie was missing
plot lines and said I didn't have any
[ __ ] money to make that film alright
give me a break um one guy just had to
take a stab at Sookie in the [ __ ]
reddit comments oh yeah
yeah there's a guy picking apart my
lyrics too and I was like dude half the
[ __ ] posts on here what like oh that
what do you know what do you when I know
I know we're not like we're like real
we're not like real rappers but like you
famous Dex post something you're not
gonna go through his genius and be like
what the [ __ ] does this mean this is
looking for it no that was another um
those one that got me someone's head
they clearly have ghost writers no [ __ ]
you man [ __ ] you they had me chuckling
yeah that's kind of a good that's a good
hate comment no no that's great I took
that as a convey that is a compliment
I'm like Danny these are good enough
that we had to hire someone yeah that's
great I'll take that hell yeah Quinn
Miller was in the studio with us yeah
exactly
you know after after his whole situation
with Drake who is a who was rice gums
ghostwriter oh oh what's that dude's
name um what do you like something like
gun rapper I forget what his name was
hold on all right hold on I got this
thing called the Internet hold on price
come Coast rapper
ghost writer ghost writer you wrote
ghost rapper oh not here
my brain is [ __ ] off anyway anyway
yeah and then there was like the
majority of calm or like the know then
there was a bunch of comments being like
oh wow this isn't a joke anymore this
isn't this the humorous subtle man does
it have to be like slap my penis on her
pizza sometimes it's fun to go in and
just not write about like a grander
concept like we say I mean [ __ ] dude
we went to the studio the other day and
we were like hammering home this we're
trying to nail down this constant
contest a song taking us [ __ ] forever
just to come up with like a yeah a
broader thing and sometimes that's not
fun so unless we would want to just go
in and write stupid lyrics and yeah and
you know the way that beat happened was
he started making it yeah it was weird
and cool and so we just started writing
just yeah random [ __ ] I mean we did
enough mean that and we're like it
sounds cool didn't even end up finishing
it all we had on the after the first
session was we just had the first eight
bars and then we had the chorus and then
make that chorus is interesting too
because like you had put down the first
four and oh sorry guys it's the my
mixtape that's good letting enough time
pass that it doesn't appear like you
have a new bit and then you go to the
old go yeah yeah that's good I couldn't
think of a new way yeah that's good and
then [ __ ] and then I don't know where
I got the idea to just like like chop
the [ __ ] chorus uh-huh just to go
dead a broke [ __ ] like woah oh yeah
that was sick I don't know where that
came from and then I don't know yeah
that that was that was fun but like that
walk man short Kings use supers in the
sessions like they were all kind of had
that same vibe where it was like we're
just having fun yeah you know just going
in and like putting [ __ ] down yeah you
know and I think with broke [ __ ] we
just lay low
just make like some of the the lines
funny but yeah it's not going for this
brand or thing cuz we went in for that
grander thing two days ago not only was
not fun it just turned out bad yeah it's
just like well I mean not to say that
that's not a bad thing or not to say
that that's a bad thing because
sometimes that ends up being yeah great
like I've and others she likes I think I
still think stinky money is great and
some like that mhm
that also has like a yeah bigger bigger
finger theme yeah but I think in terms
of like you know um I think going with
subtleties like solid like the other
shade we worked on the second track we
did on Monday that's got a lot of
potential I sent it to one person and he
was like uh he was like damn so y'all
like really stepping away from satire
and when I told him the premise he goes
oh [ __ ] yes really I was it was exactly
and again yeah it was exactly what we
wanted [ __ ] yeah that's a so that one
that one I'm really happy I'm really
excited there's odd was like this is it
like insanely good yeah yeah that that
is like that's gonna be great um yeah so
that one i'm hype for it that one is is
dope and and so it's not to say like I
think some people you know to be fair I
think some people you know they enjoy
the you know very obvious comedic you
know music and that's not going away
yeah you know I just think we're trying
to so it's like we went that way for a
while
and then we're gone the other way where
it's like it's maybe too subtle and
we're just trying to find that like you
know in the middle feel yeah it's like
you know because we still want it to be
you know listenable like mo that's
that's the most important goal is yeah
have it be fun to listen to like yeah
music that's to comedic it's like you
turn it on yeah go I get the point and
then you don't listen again yeah and we
don't we don't want it to be that like
we want it to be something that you can
enjoy many times and I think we're
getting better at doing that yeah
definitely some of the stuff I don't
know some stuff they were making
recently I feel like it actually had
some
replay value to it I think if anything I
want to say thanks everyone like who
listens to it and [ __ ] with it because I
think you just it helps us it gives just
give us a little more confidence to be
like alright like we can try new things
yeah you know and I appreciate a lot of
people being open to hey yeah I could I
could feel that in like the you know the
vast majority of the comments I like it
it meant a lot that people were like oh
man like this isn't this isn't obviously
funny but I like this you know and and
and I and I 1,000% appreciate feedback
like oh damn Cody like I like this like
I like your voice here and I like you
without auto-tune yeah that's like the
best thing you can ask oh yeah a hundred
percent you know 100 percent I even
appreciate comments where people are
like yeah you know I wasn't feeling this
one but then they like they list it out
is I I appreciate that way more than
[ __ ] yeah you guys are [ __ ]
sellout yeah that's a brainless comment
and even think about what was going yeah
this just just just leave man you'd even
like watch yeah you know what the [ __ ]
uses half of this is a [ __ ] act just
listens to a whole podcast yo like three
minutes of that was a [ __ ] ad what
the [ __ ] I just got it underwear
advertised to me for a minute dude by
two guys oh dude I feel weird right now
if I had more energy I was gonna hit a
hill dude what the [ __ ] but I can't what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I can never
scream like this some dude some one of
the guys I read had said my web be
creeping on the 10 I'm feeling weird
again he's like what is this a pedophile
joke no do you think the 10 is a highway
freeway that we drive on all the [ __ ]
time how do you not know the 10 in LA is
that I mean I guess I would I wouldn't
know no no not like five in Iowa you
[ __ ] [ __ ] how do you know but my
wit be creepin on the ten you should
have said the five yeah yeah I shoulda
double damn you should respond to that
comment and double down yeah actually no
I was referring to the freeway but I had
a five-year-old in my car and I'm
creeping on a five-year-old on the 10
and I'm feeling weird again and I'm
feeling weird again it's because I get
anxiety every single time I own my road
yeah that's not that no no it's just
abstract that's [ __ ] poetry baby and
it's just abstracted maybe it's knocked
out but who cares it sounds sick yeah
all right I know I'm looking around
dicks yeah yeah it's just I'm there I'm
enough I just in general I just want to
say thank you all it does mean a lot to
us that's why we're harping on it yeah
yeah was because we care
you